hey everyone I'm Abbi sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen so today as you can see
we're not in the usual studio we're
currently building a new exciting studio
and I cannot wait to share it with you
guys but of course everything takes
longer than expected in construction so
we're working in a temporary space today
and so today we're gonna be talking
about something that was heavily
requested that is Stephanie butter mores
all in videos so I'm really excited to
speak about this because it's just
something that I'm personally really
interested in as well and I did quite a
lot of research in preparation for this
video so that's why this took me so long
so basically Stephanie butter more is a
fitness enthusiast and a former fitness
bikini competitor and she's also no
dummy she's got a PhD in pathology and
cellular biology so she infuses a lot of
science into her content which you know
I really appreciate and in some of her
past video she's really kind of broke
down the great lengths that she's had to
go to to kind of cut body fat increase
muscle and succeed in the bikini fitness
competitive world unfortunately in that
process she experienced a lot of
unpleasant symptoms that we often
associate with salon we call
hypothalamic amenorrhea which is a very
common condition in the kind of
aesthetic sports world so the term
amenorrhea basically means loss of
period or loss of your menstrual cycle
and the main causes of amenorrhea in
general are low caloric intake low body
fat excessive exercise stress and of
course genetic predisposition and you
don't need to look like a fitness model
to be at risk for hypothalamic
amenorrhea which i'm now going to call a
che because it is a big word and that's
gonna save me a lot of energy but
cutting calories or over exercising at
any size can put you at greater risk of
things like infertility osteoporosis and
premature cardiovascular disease in fact
an expert review in the Journal of
Clinical Endocrinology and metabolism
found that cutting calories by just 470
calories per day was enough to increase
people's risk of a che especially when
paired with intense exercise so while
Stephanie did not actually
lose her period she did experience a lot
of the same symptoms that we find and
associate with over-exercising
caloric restriction Nha in general so
let's take a look
deficit or having a che I was
experiencing things like being really
really cold all the time I was tired I
feel like my strength to a really big
hit and most inconveniently I was
ravenously hungry so some of the most
common side effects of har things like
feeling really cold really tired low
libido low bone density brittle hair
nails bowel issues decreased strength
etc so basically all the energy in your
body is directed towards the essential
functions and in the body like breathing
and things that are not essential to to
healthy living like I don't know
beautiful long luscious hair get kind of
put by the wayside okay so let's talk
about this extreme hunger thing because
I feel like a lot of people who have
been in the throes of diet culture and
restriction have probably experienced
something like this
so let's see what she has to say about
it that's just what I've had you to
maintain a lower weight however I've
gotten to the point where it's getting
harder than ever to do this to stop
because I'm so hungry all the time and
it's quite frankly pretty exhausting and
seemingly unsustainable and genetically
I do think that I just have a really
high or large capacity I think a lot of
this is due to genetics and I think from
dieting I think my hunger has gotten
worse so what I want to try to do is I
want to try to fix it and I'm going to
be going all-in in an attempt to fix it
so this makes sense just knowing what we
know about dieting in general and for
someone who is a bikini and fitness
competitor who probably had to diet
pretty hard I'm not really surprised
about this kind of extreme hunger
symptom but basically what's happening
here is that when we restrict calories
we see an uptick in our stress hormone
cortisol
which with our hunger and satiety
hormone so gralen and leptin and leptin
is stored in our fat cells so we shrink
our fat cells because we've lost weight
we see a decline in leptin and our
hypothalamus kind of freaks out and
demands for us to eat more in an attempt
to restore those fat stores
hence the extreme hunger I mean isn't
the body just so amazing so with all
this said Stephanie being kind of a
science minded person that she is
reached out to dr. Nicola Rinaldi who is
the leading expert in H a H a recovery
she's the author of no period now what
which is a book that I've read and I
found just so fascinating and packed
with so much information so if you might
be struggling with H a I definitely
recommend this this book but from their
conversation this is what dr. Rinaldi
recommended if you are truly committed
to rescuing your cycle she recommends
jumping up to at least 2,500 calories a
day and cutting back her altogether
illuminating intense bouts of exercise
and if you've been restricting your
calories and training really intensely
for a long time yes you will gain some
weight which is kind of the point but
granted this may not be the appropriate
route for everyone okay so just a
paraphrase exactly that dr. Rinaldi
recommends a minimum of 2,500 calories
per day with no maximum so really it's
just a matter of kind of eating to
satiety and cutting out any any intense
exercise and like she said you're gonna
gain weight that's kind of the point but
this is the idea of going all-in so what
is going all-in and how does it differ
from traditional methods of weight
restoration like reverse dieting so
basically reverse dieting is often
called the diet after the diet basically
what it involves is a small caloric
surplus over a longer period of time so
sometimes weeks sometimes months and the
idea is to slowly gain weight restore
hormones restore the metabolism without
seeing like a huge shoot up in weight or
body fat so a little bit of backstory
here during periods of caloric
restriction what we often see is the
body trying to prevent starvation by
slowing down the metabolic rate so that
it burns less energy or less calories
and then when that person kind of comes
off the diet and starts eating normally
again okay more calories what we see is
the body tries to return to its previous
weight and it does so by storing a lot
of the energy as fat because it's a safe
reserve of energy for the body so what
ends up happening is that we see
people's weight shoot up quite rapidly
after kind of coming off the diet and
this is often what we call post
starvation obesity pardon the offensive
term but for Stephanie reverse dieting
didn't really work because although she
saw some weight gain she was still
experiencing a lot of the same symptoms
associated with h.a things like extreme
hunger so with that said that is why
Stephanie was going all-in so it sounds
like quite the stark departure from
Stephanie's kind of fitness model days
so let's talk a little bit more about
all in so I first want to touch on the
idea of set point theory because this is
very important to kind of the premise of
all in so set point theory basically
means that your body tries really hard
to maintain its comfortable weight range
by regulating its metabolism so
basically it will speed metabolism up
when it's being overfed and it'll slow
metabolism down when the body's being
underfed in an effort to eliminate large
fluctuations in one's weight so this is
exactly why most people just regain the
weight that they lost after they go on a
diet your body will fight like hell to
get back to where it wants to be and
this is one of the many reasons why I
find it just so idiotic that we would
ever criticize somebody based on their
weight because our weight has
thing to do with moral character
willpower or what we do or eat our body
literally just wants to be what it wants
to be and it'll do whatever it takes and
shut down every other body process
including reproduction just to get back
there unfortunately research suggests
that set points go up but they rarely
come down and one of the best ways to
increase your set point is to diet and
that's largely because one of the ways
that your body fights to regain its set
point is through this extreme hunger
it's through those fluctuations in
ghrelin and leptin our hunger and
satiety hormones other ways that our
body fights to maintains that point are
things like a decline in our thyroid
hormone which makes us fatigued and
makes us move less and increase in other
a lot of the gastric hormones which
increases our hunger and an increase in
gastric emptying which increases our
hunger so Stephanie believes that by
going all-in
she'll kick-start her metabolism send it
working into high gear she'll eventually
kind of reach a weight plateau where
she'll no longer feel that extreme
hunger sensation so she'll need fewer
calories to feel satiated and she
believes she'll then kind of lose this
overshoot weight while maintaining a
healthy active lifestyle so I asked dr.
Rinaldi about this actually and she told
me that she doesn't like to make
promises to women that you will
eventually lose some of this overshoot
weight
but yes sometimes it does happen once
you start eating a little bit more
intuitively after having to kind of semi
force-feed yourself in the early stages
of this process so having said that you
might lose some overshoot weight if you
want to call it that or you might just
stay the weight that you plateaued at if
that is the weight that your body just
naturally wants to be so one of the big
questions I know I'm going to be getting
here is just going all-in carry any
risks well I think the the one that
we're most concerned about is refeeding
syndrome refeeding syndrome is when a
star starving person eventually eats
again and the shock to the body causes
kind of fluctuations and shifts in
electrolytes and fluids this is why
making
any extreme changes to your diet ideally
should be done under medical supervision
but is going all in a risk factor for
refeeding syndrome so some of the risk
factors for refeeding syndrome include a
BMI under 15 little or no food for 10
days or more low electrolyte levels and
use or misuse of alcohol or drugs
including diuretics so based on the
information that I have about Stephanie
I would say that she's probably not high
risk but again I'm not her doctor so
this is definitely not diagnostic but we
definitely would see this more often
with eating disorder patients okay so
how does going all-in work out for
Stephanie last months I have been all-in
and I've been eating about 5,000
calories a day
well 4820 to be exact according to my
fitness pal and that number was not a
target or anything I didn't have any
specific number in mind that was just
how many calories it took for me to feel
satiated every single day okay so after
going all in Stephanie was consuming
about 5,000 calories at the beginning of
her therapy and she gained about 18
pounds after the first month her latest
update shares that she's gained about 30
pounds to date and she's unsure if she's
plateaued or if she's still got further
to go but she seems so happy and
energetic it's I loved watching her
videos she also talks about one of the
amazing things she's not as hungry
anymore she just she doesn't have the
ravenous appetite that she used to have
at the beginning of this process so I
think that alone is huge progress for
Stephanie so I know you're thinking oh
my god 5,000 calories seems like a ton
for somebody of you know Stephanie's
size but actually you know this is not
uncommon especially for women who are
struggling with a chay or trying to
recover from an eating disorder it's
very common that we need a high amount
of calories to kind of kick that
hypothalamus back into gear so 5,000
4,000 summer in that range is very very
common for this kind of recovery
so early on in her recovery process
Stephanie also talks about some of the
symptoms and side effects of going
all-in so let's take a look kind of
started experiencing a lot of the side
effects that come along with eating that
many calories I was super sweaty and a
hot all the time my face was always
really swollen and puffy in the morning
so at the beginning of going all-in I
kind of felt like every single day woke
up my face was super puffy and today is
like one of the first days that I feel
like it looks pretty normal it doesn't
look super puffy I do feel like my face
has more volume and it just simply due
to the fact that I've gained like 13
pounds but it doesn't look puffy like I
just got like punched in the cheeks or
something or have like an allergic
reaction which is how my face was
looking right at the beginning of being
all in like so when it comes to the
sweating heavily restricting calories
prevents your body from kind of
regulating temperature through sweating
and this paired with maybe some improved
thyroid functions might be why she was
experiencing some of those symptoms as
for the kind of swelling feeling or kind
of edema this might be because she's
consuming more calories which poly means
more carbohydrates and an uptick in
carbohydrates means storage of glycogen
which is stored with water so there is
some water attention there and depending
on her food choices you know if she was
consuming just more salt than to what
she's used to the carbs and the salt can
cause some water attention especially if
you're not used to it but over time your
body would adjust I want to talk about
where I think that Stephanie is really
rocking it first of all her enormous
amount of bravery for coming out and
kind of making this process public
especially when she has built a whole
brand around restriction and dieting and
and kind of fitness competitions and all
of that in one of her videos she is in
Bali and she's crying because you know
her belt doesn't fit around her bathing
suit anymore as her body has been
changing so rapidly and not only is this
moment like so raw and relatable but it
also proves that this journey is not
a linear one and then it's possible to
be body-positive and love and appreciate
your body even if you don't feel like a
rockstar every single day part of being
body positive is accepting yourself and
being kind to yourself so thinking that
like you have to do body positivity
perfectly is just not productive number
two she's prioritizing her health energy
and future fertility over aesthetic
goals and being thin well I do hear some
kind of fat phobic language occasionally
in her talking I also get that it's
really hard to unlearn that kind of
stuff when you mean part of toxic diet
culture for so long so I really
appreciate though that she's trying to
make space in the fitness community for
different sized bodies and also she
talks about how you know having more
body fat does not equate to being less
healthy and in fact in her recent video
she talks about how you know having more
energy and eating more and having more
body fat actually has had some kind of
fitness and training benefits as well
number three she seeks out the advice of
experts who are actually evidence-based
so I was really happy to see that
Stephanie reached out to dr. Rinaldi who
is a leading expert in h.a and someone
that I also reached out to for this
review so that's fantastic Stephanie
also talks about how you know she's not
qualified to tell people what to do or
how to eat she just wants to share her
own experience for people's kind of
learning and entertainment that is
really the responsible thing to do when
you have such a massive following I mean
every body is going to be different and
have different needs so it's always best
to seek out professional advice when it
comes to making drastic changes to your
diet lifestyle
I just want to flag that we want to make
sure that the people that we are
recommending our followers to for help
our actual professionals I know that
there's like a lot of great influencers
out there who are anti diet and Pro
health and may have some good
information for example I know that
Stephanie kind of brought forward
another influencer named Kayla to talk
about her experience and that's great
super inspiring however these are not a
replacement for an actual dietician and
therapists team number four stephanie
vows to stop tracking her macros and
calories and weighing herself I'm really
glad that Stephanie mentions this
because I do think it's hard for people
to learn to intuitively and not fall
back into kind of disordered eating
behaviors when there's such a focus on
tracking and calculating and keeping
tabs on weight size food intake etc I
get that that was definitely like an
important part of the process early on
and and it typically is for things like
a chay or eating disorder recovery but
once we're kind of through that and
focusing more on learning to eat
intuitively we really have to kind of
let those rules go and finally she talks
about buying new clothes so I think this
is a really fantastic step in recovery
from restrictive eating and under
feeding but and I recognize that you
know Stephanie's I've seen a privileged
stained place where she's able to
purchase whole new wardrobe but even
going to your local donation bin or
doing a clothing swap finding kind of
other more cost-effective ways to get
some clothing that fits and feels good
is a really important step when it comes
to kind of shedding that diet mentality
but you know being in clothes that don't
fit just doesn't feel good emotionally
or physically even if you're totally
kind of in a wait new Trull space but in
doctor and all these books she talks
about how we can think about our to
small clothing as being kind of like our
unwell close and that shedding those
clothes are getting rid of them is a way
to shed our unhealthy relationship with
food and our restrictive behaviors and
kind of that diet culture and mentality
so next I want to talk about some
potential ways that I think that
Stephanie can kind of further her
journey and kind of work towards a
better relationship with food so first
of all getting rid of the diet culture
talk now I get that a lot of it is kind
of for jokes but I remember there's this
like one scene where she's kind of
loosening up her her belt on her fanny
pack and talking about how oh you know a
backpack doesn't judge you when you get
fat but a fanny pack does again I get
that this is just kind of like the
giggles for her and just kind of basic
banter with her her partner but there is
still some fat phobic talk in her videos
and I also think that you know there's a
lot of talk about clean eating and
getting in her cheat days to kind of
get in all her cravings and things like
that so it seems like she's not
completely all-in from a psychological
perspective quite yet but I also get
that it's gonna take a long time to
unlearn and undo all the damage that dye
culture has has had on her life and I've
already actually seen an improvement in
her latest video so I do think that
Stephanie's definitely on the right
track I just wanted to kind of flag that
here before some of you go and watch her
full videos because I do think it could
be triggering for some people number two
she still has some rules here she talks
about like a 7525 rule so she describes
how her kind of all-in diet is 75% kind
of clean food really kind of healthy
nutrient-dense food and 25% is like junk
food because she likes balance so like
you'll see her eating donuts and and
cakes and other kind of sweet things
that she would associate with like her
cheat days again I think this is just
kind of like part of the process and
unlearning that diet culture piece she's
so used to having these kind of cheat
days interspersed between like severe
restriction and over time as she really
hones those intuitive eating skills
she'll find that she doesn't need to be
so deliberate in her planning for meals
and she also won't need those cheat days
so here's the thing I hate the idea of
cheat days I think that they assign way
too much moral value to food and when
instead you actually just start to kind
of like listen to your body and eat
intuitively it's very possible to feel
satisfied on a single piece of chocolate
and not feel the need to kind of overdo
it right after and yeah some days you're
gonna want that second piece of
chocolate cake because it tastes so good
but because you're not judging yourself
and you're not feeling the need to kind
of jump right back on that restrict
binge repent repeat cycle again and
again you won't feel the need to totally
overdo it and finally she is still
exercising quite heavily despite dr.
Rinaldi's recommendation so I just want
to flag that you know this might work
for her because I know she did not lose
her period so she just had some of the
other symptoms of a chay
but I wanted people to know that for a
lot of women who are struggling with a
chay you know it really has to be very
gentle exercise because
we can see that uptick in cortisol which
again kind of triggers a lot of these
symptoms and can prevent you from
getting your cycle back not everybody
everyone's unique and that is really why
we want to seek out kind of individual
help from a professional when we're
dealing with AJ so I want to close off
with something that I heard I think
Kayla say in one of Stephanie's video
and that is the more that you control
food the more it controls you yes yes
yes your body is so intuitive and so
smart and when we just allow it to kind
of run its course and feel hungry and
feel satisfied on its own terms we
really can fall into its healthiest
happiest weight that is actually the
best place for us metabolically
reproductively everything in terms of
all of the benefits
Stephanie talks about how going all-in
made her feel fuller more energized made
her kind of recover better from workouts
which absolutely makes sense because
it's very hard to be anabolic and
catabolic at the same time and most
importantly she talks about how it just
made her happier and then actually meter
connects with her partner more which is
not surprising because we connect with
people through food overall I think that
stephanie has made some major strides in
terms of having a better relationship
with food and her body and while there's
definitely still some kind of diet
culture evidence bubbling on the surface
I think that's to be expected just based
on how long she's been entrenched in it
but judging by her commitment I have no
doubt that Stephanie is going to be a
huge amazing cheerleader for the
intuitive eating movement so thank you
so much Stephanie for your bravery for
sharing your story for sharing this
journey and I'm looking forward to
seeing more videos and updates well guys
I hope you enjoyed this video if you did
be sure to give it the thumbs up leave
me a comment below with other kind of
diets or youtubers you want me to review
I also would love to know if you have
any QA kind of questions for me cuz I'm
gonna be doing a Q&A video very soon and
I would love to collect all of your your
juicy questions
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]
[Music]
you